today's one minute Monday is take
responsibility if your company isn't
where you want it to be yet if you're
not getting the results you want if
you're not getting the momentum that you
want yet you got to look in the mirror
it's on you to step up and take
responsibility to fix it here's a quick
example one of my customers wrote in to
my website and was unhappy with one of
the policies that I had on my website
and when team member got the email and
wrote back and wrote to me and said evan
is a policy question I don't know if you
want to get involved or not you know I'm
not quite sure how I should respond if
it should be long-winded or just a quick
response and instead of me writing to
him so he can write to her so she could
write back to him so he can read back to
me
I just wrote back to her directly and I
told her why we created the policy what
it's all about why it's important for us
and teaming up stay as a customer she's
like our policies you know that may
happen and that's okay but it does a
couple things
one it cuts the timeout right so you got
the answer right it comes right from the
top there's no back-and-forth there's no
hey can you ask Kevin about this or is
there any wiggle room it's coming right
from me the second thing is though it
backs up my team member and he knows
that if he ever has a problem if we ever
have a question if there's anything
something that he can't handle he can
come to me and I've got his back I'm
going to respond and take the time
personally to do it you got to step up
and take responsibility if your company
is not where you want it to be yet it's
not your team members fault it's not the
economy's fault it's not your customers
fault it's on you to start taking action
look in the mirror because that's the
person is going to come and save you
there's nobody else coming to save your
business it's on you and when you
realize that and take responsibility for
everything that's happening your
business you're going to start seeing
results belief
you